so i was born in india
uh this is just a small part of my big
beautiful family there
i have actually
50 5-0 first cousins
most of us have a couple of kids
and so all of this leads me to believe
the united nations when they tell us
that by 2100 the world will have a
population of almost 11 billion people
that is three billion more people than
the planet houses today
to house all of those people
we need to build
about 2.4
trillion
square feet of new built space
now to give you a sense of scale
that is the equivalent of adding to the
planet in new york city
every month
for the next 40 years
now i'm a new yorker and an architect
but this scares even me um
but this is not a scary talk i promise
you
i i
i
i know
what you're probably thinking which is
we are already experiencing
severe
impacts from climate change how can the
world house another three billion people
and how can their housing needs be part
of the solution rather than part of the
problem
could new housing
be carbon negative
meaning that it offsets or sequesters
more carbon than it produces
now for our big existing cities there is
a lot of hope in clean energy grids
fueled by renewables like solar wind
nuclear and geothermal
but the fact is we are still a ways away
from getting fully clean power grids in
our existing cities where most of this
population growth is going to occur
and that's true because of the problems
with everything from transmission lines
to the politics of nuclear energy so
clean grids are a really important part
of the solution
but they don't help us that much right
at this moment
what we can do today what we have
existing technology for
is to build net zero single family homes
in sunny climates in particular solar
panels work very very well because it's
a lot of roof area relative to very few
occupants but these things they're
hardly a panacea
in part because they're very expensive
to build
but more problematically because they
induce
car-oriented sprawl
and i don't care if the cars are
electric or autonomous sprawl is sprawl
and it leads to a loss of wetlands a
loss of forests a loss of farms and a
loss of community
so maybe you're thinking
the right answer to how's our coming
building boom
are towers
and look i've actually been called
professor skyscraper i love a great
tower but the reality is we are very far
away from developing carbon negative
towers and the reason is towers are
energy intensive to build and operate
they house a lot of people which is
great but they have very little roof
area to effectively use solar and
similarly like wind turbines at the top
all of that stuff barely makes a dent
on top of that most skyscrapers are
built out of steel and concrete which
have a very high degree of embodied
energy now i hold out a lot of hope for
a technology known as mass timber
construction which would allow us to
build tall towers
out of environmentally friendly and fire
retardant wood that's actually a carbon
sink but we are a ways away from
widespread adoption of that technology i
also hold out hope for the idea that
windows
could harness solar power but the idea
that we have effective and affordable
solar glass in the near future that's
even more nascent than mass timber
so for towers to really be sustainable
we need those clean energy grids that we
spoke about but we don't have them
available to us today
so we have a paradox
how do we house all of these people how
do we build urban carbon negative
housing
in a means that's technologically
attainable
and broadly affordable and do that today
because i'm tired of talking about 2050.
[Applause]
i believe that the answer's hiding in
plain sight that there is what i call a
goldilocks scale
that sits between the scale of housing
and towers
two to three story housing
that should actually look very familiar
to most of you because we built the most
beloved parts of our cities with it
the row houses of boston the hutong
districts of beijing
most of the fabric of edinburgh
what we now build in this scale
are largely cheap suburban townhomes
they're banal they're not sustainable
they're not walkable they're certainly
not beautiful
but
could they provide a hint a framework
for a human scale way of solving this
problem that is great for both the
climate and our societies
this goldilocks framework
hits the sweet spot between the number
of people it can house
and the amount of roof area we need to
provide them and their communities
power it can be built out of simple
local materials like wood
or brick
both of which have relatively low
embodied energy and can be built by
local workers
and the solar panels up above could be
supplemented with state-of-the-art
battery systems that level out solar
supply and user demand
similarly we can have electric
state-of-the-art air conditioning and
heating systems this exists today that
can create thermal storage so what that
means is it can produce ice or hot water
off peak for use on peak
this housing could compost food scraps
and solid waste and turn it into usable
soils or protein for animal feed and i
think most importantly this kind of
housing can provide
affordable communal equitable housing
for communities in dire need of it and i
work with a lot of these communities and
i know how much demand there is for this
out there
speaking of communities
i want to emphasize that this is not a
one size fits all solution this is a
framework it's a template we can work
with communities to make this housing
appealing visually and socially make it
socially and racially mixed
integrate it into the lives of existing
communities and when it's built into our
cities
what it means is that it's dense enough
to support mass transit like light rail
express buses
bikes
that are networks that plug into
jobs schools parks and other daily
destinations in our cities
this housing is compact enough
that it leaves room for lots of trees
and ground cover that means that we can
lower storm water impacts we can reduce
the heat island effect we can lower the
demand for air conditioning and for
every family that lives in an apartment
like this it's one less house
destroying farms and forests
our collaborating engineers at thornton
thomas eddie have assured us that this
is the lowest carbon footprint per
person means of habitation
while also providing a sustainable use
of land on our planet i want you now
imagine with me that we deployed this
goldilocks framework in two places that
i love dearly new york and calcutta very
different places but they have these big
booming downtowns but they also have
these growing outskirts that experience
a lot of sprawl so they have sites like
this that are near mass transit but
imagine if on these sites we instead of
building sprawl
built this goldilocks framework now that
would manifest in two very very
different ways different materials
different cultural expressions but it
would give us carbon negative
transit-rich
joyous
places for people to live and raise
their families
now you may be thinking so this is his
big idea small-scale housing solar
panels above light rail below known
technologies throughout all organized
into these affordable green
neighborhoods
even if you believed me that this was
carbon negative
how many of our 11 billion people could
this possibly house it's such a modest
model
well it turns out if all of us lived at
this scale
all 11 billion of us
would use up a land mass equivalent to
the size of france
now i have a feeling that the french
don't want us all invading their country
but
i make this point to make a larger point
which is
we can all live in this transit-rich
carbon-negative affordable way
and leave the vast majority of the
planet for nature for agriculture for
clean oceans we can do this
we know that residential energy use is
so voracious
that this model
offsets so much carbon
it actually more than offsets
all of the cars in the world
the impact of this would be staggering
so yes
we can go to 11
11 billion people we don't need to fear
our neighbors
we don't have a lack of land or
technology
we just have a lack of vision because
the answers are hiding in plain sight
thank you very much